so okay we already covered the fake fan
rally for fans of the Philadelphia
Eagles who were disinvited from the
White House but it was just random
people who showed up right not
Philadelphia Eagles fans so anyway I've
got cringe video for you or as Jon
Stewart might have called it years ago a
moment of Zen video I have video for you
from yesterday's fake fan rally where
Donald Trump tries to sing god bless
america
but clearly doesn't know the words
beyond like the first line but he
doesn't stop singing instead he does
this sort of awkward I don't even know
what it he does something awkward I
don't even really know how to describe
it in the English language check out the
video which I know is not going to do
much for our audio audience people
listening on the radio in to the audio
podcast but if you're just listening I
would encourage you to check out the
video when you have a moment Trump just
looks confused during the singing of God
Bless America here
[Music]
berries in you
[Music]
this is a moment indistinguishable from
an episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm right
I mean that this is Larry David who has
a better grasp of the lyrics to this
song Trump or the Philadelphia Eagles
players who were disinvited from the
White House and it's not any better
during the national anthem either
remember this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway the really sad thing about all of
this is that we have a government or I
guess an administration I should say
that is increasingly obsessed with these
mandatory displays of the version of
patriotism that they approve of right
kneeling during the national anthem to
shine a light on racial inequalities
that's not patriotic mandatory standing
motionless looking at the flag during
any playing of the national anthem
that's real patriotism refusing to bake
a cake for a gay wedding
that's a patriotic expression of one's
First Amendment right
kneeling during the national anthem
which of course doesn't refuse anybody
service on the basis of their sexual
orientation that's apparently not the
flavor of free speech that should be
respected and certainly not celebrated
if you're part of this administration so
let me see if I can explain this layer
one of the sadness here is that the
administration is focused on things like
fake and staged patriotism and the
anthem and what football players do
right that's sort of a basic tragedy of
what's going on layer two of the tragedy
is that tons of people are falling for
it while we continue to have no net
neutrality we're destroying the
environment our health care system is a
disaster wages are completely stagnant
40% of Americans don't have 400 dollars
to cover an unexpected emergency and
there is so much at stake here and
Republicans and Trump are moving
backwards on the things that really
matter and Trump has actually
successfully made it about the national
anthem and kneeling and singing songs
and the only hope here you know what the
only hope is write pad I mean I'm a
broken record on this at this point
gotta get to the polls got a vote got a
vote in 2018 got a vote in 2018 and I
don't know about you but I'm
increasingly skeptical that that's going
to happen because I know you've been
following it Pat I've been following it
voter enthusiasm from the left has waned
a little bit the advantage on the
generic ballot for Democrats has waned
I'm actually very worried people aren't
gonna vote yesterday was the biggest
primary day of the season yeah
I mixed results I think I mean I wasn't
the best night for Democrats but we're
gonna cover that more on the bonus show
yeah but we'll talk about the primary
results from yesterday but I am NOT I am
NOT massively optimistic about the
midterm elections unfortunately send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by Cody
which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that wants to revolutionize how
we send and receive online payments cody
stands for currency of the internet and
the goal is to build an infrastructure
for online payments that simple
transparent trustworthy instantaneous as
well as scalable and today's payment
solutions have a number of different
trust and usability problems whether
it's between consumers or between
businesses or between consumers and
businesses and Cody wants to solve a lot
of those problems through their currency
and platform which unlike a lot of the
cryptos and block chains that are out
there have actually been created
specifically and solely to be used for
payments cody has set out to do this by
using innovative base layer protocol in
the form of a directed acyclic graph
based ledger built from transactions
connected through time by harnessing
trust based algorithms if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about cody and their initial
coin offering in the links below this
video this is not financial advice and
everybody should do their own research